let's go to a caller from the 774 area
code potentially a local caller who's
calling today from 774.
hello is that me that's you oh hi david
uh
sorry about the stream getting taken
down last night oh yeah it was no good
it was a shame uh but i just wanted to
uh take a minute and expand upon the
segment from last week uh
you had talked about um or you had
pointed out
that at a recent rally in north carolina
trump's line was actually a kkk slogan
the love it or leave it
from that area and i recall the story
from the thom hartmann program
from back in the 2016 election cycle
about how i think it was his ex-wife who
had pointed out that
he carried a copy of hitler's speech
book with him and that was like
cooperated by
now let me be clear just because i don't
want to have any grammatical ambiguity
trump's ex-wife pointed out that trump
did that you're not saying
tom hartman's ex-wife says tom's
carrying this no no no not tom
i'm not sure about that yeah so trump's
ex had uh had stated that he had a copy
of the new order which was
hitler's uh or a compilation of hitler's
speeches yeah i think it was that he had
the book on his nightstand
not carrying it around yeah the only
thing that causes me to question that is
i don't think trump reads so i don't
it's hard for me to imagine yeah
maybe he had it on audiobook too i don't
know yeah
very possible um but just thinking about
that
i i thought it would be kind of
interesting like uh just looking at the
way that he
you know kind of disseminates his
rhetoric um
that just to extrapolate on that like if
that were the case it makes a lot of
sense because
uh and actually sam cedar just had a
segment about this
in which trump was barking back at al
sharpton for calling him out
and about the baltimore tweets and he
was saying
how he was the least racist person in
the world yeah
and that he's done more as in his two
and a half years as president than any
president ever has before and i just
i literally shot like snot out of my
nose i was laughing so hard
at the absurdity of that statement like
yeah forget abraham lincoln forget
anybody who's done any abolition work
you know
what did they help well it's so obvious
that now this is how the
you're actually pointing out exactly how
the trumpists will defend it they'll say
guys trump's being symbolic he's not
literally saying that he's done more
than abraham lincoln or martin luther
king
he's just saying right in the modern era
given what a president in 2019 can
do this guy's done a lot and that's what
you don't want to give him credit for so
they already know
at any time that trump says something
that's not literally true
that's hyperbolic they say it's
symbolism but trump's really doing a
good job
yeah and in that uh the sam cedar
segment from last night he also pointed
out how politico had a piece
uh talking about how this is this dog
whistle uh approach that he's taking is
literally the strategy that they had
lined up that he was going to attempt to
use for reelection
that's right and that he's just actively
seeking his next kaepernick and i
thought that was quite a good take on
this this is what i've been saying for
weeks now this you
you can't win by exposing the things
trump is saying
because it's a strategy and his
followers like it so it's like
you know it's what you're you're only
going to convince them that he's doing
exactly what they want to see him doing
that's not a strategy that's why we've
got to win on turnout
absolutely well thanks for taking my
call okay thanks appreciate the call
uh great hope to hear from you again